en las reuniones acostumbro poner a
jugar a mis amigos y familiares con
dados para ganarse premios ocultos pongo
varios premios de diversos tamaños y
formas al centro y para ganarlos se dice
un número del 2 al 12
después se lanzan dos dados si la suma
de lo que salga en los dos dados es
igual al número que se dijo se puede
tomar un premio del centro es muy
divertido porque todo depende del azar y
no sabes qué premio te llevas ni tampoco
qué número sumar a los dados usemos las
matemáticas para saber con qué números
tenemos más probabilidades de ganar así
cuando te ponga en este tipo de juegos
en una reunión en teoría sabrás cómo es
más probable ganar aunque siga sin saber
qué regalos están misteriosamente
envueltos cuando tiramos dos dados los
resultados pueden ser desde el 2 hasta
el 12 si dices que el resultado será uno
seguro pierdes no hay forma de que dos
dados sumen uno
ahora coloquemos una tabla con los
resultados de cada dado y vamos a darles
un color diferente para distinguirlos al
igual que para el lado rosa para el azul
tenemos los posibles resultados de 12
4 5 y 6
así los resultados para los datos
combinados serán las demás casillas
cuando el dado azul caiga en 1 y el rosa
también el resultado será 2 si el rosa
que hay en 2 y el azul nuevamente en 1
tendremos 3 y así seguimos llenando toda
la tabla con las posibilidades que
tenemos entonces podemos confirmar que
ningún resultado es menor que dos ni
mayor que 12 tomando los resultados
combinados tenemos que para que caiga 2
sólo hay una posibilidad porque el 2
solo aparece una vez en nuestra tabla
para el 3 tenemos dos posibilidades y si
te fijas todos los números van en
diagonal y así es más fácil contarlos
tabulando esta información tenemos que
las probabilidades incrementan conforme
aumenta el resultado pero a partir del 7
disminuyen de esta manera el 7 es el
número con más probabilidades de tener
como resultado en teoría es mejor decir
7 antes de tirar los dados porque 6 de
las 36 combinaciones apunta que caerá
este número vamos a graficar esta
información para entenderla mejor
colocamos los resultados en el eje x de
la gráfica y el número de combinaciones
en el eje de la jr
al graficar los datos se ve claramente
que es más probable un resultado
conforme nos acercamos al 7 y es menos
probable conforme nos alejamos en teoría
eso es porque todos los resultados son
posibles en alguna medida sería un juego
seguro si solo se tirara con dados que
tuvieran un punto por cada o que no
hubiera ningún otro resultado posible
pero es bueno realizar este tipo de
análisis para saber que si decimos 2 ó
12 arriesgamos más a que si decimos 6 7
u 8 antes de tirar los dados puedes
intentar tirar los dados varias veces
para comprobar la gráfica si llegas a
tener este tipo de situaciones recuerda
que conviene más elegir el resultado que
tiene más probabilidades de salir aunque
con el azar no hay ninguna regla
definitiva siempre nos sorprende